[SQUEAKING][RUSTLING][CLICKING]
FRANK SCHILBACH: All
right, so welcome.
This is lecture 21 of 14.13.
We're going to talk
about poverty, as seen
through the lens of psychology.
What are we going to do?
I'm going to give you
some broad overview.
We're going to particularly
talk about this work on scarcity
by Mani et al., which is
the idea that thinking--
our thoughts about poverty
captures people's minds, which
in turn leaves less
capacity in people's minds
to do other things.
And then we're going
to talk a little bit
at the end, at least briefly,
about other deprivations
that poverty entails.
Some of this is
what I have done.
Some of this work by others.
So I want to start with
a simple observation that
is sort of at the heart of
a lot of this literature.
And the observation is that when
you look around in the world
and look for
evidence, and when you
work on poverty-related
issues, you'll
see or observe quite a few
seemingly suboptimal behaviors
among the poor.
This would be things like
lack of investment or taking
advantage of high return
investment opportunities.
This would be like investment
in fertilizer or health
investments or machines
or low savings,
in particular some things
like precautionary savings,
like being ready for shocks,
saving for the future,
for retirement, and so on.
At the same time,
sort of high return
or high interest
rate credit, people
take very high interest loans.
In part-- what I've shown
you earlier in the class,
that's particularly
prevalent among the poor.
There's some evidence of
worse performance of parenting
among poor parents, including
things like violence
against children and so on.
There is some evidence of lower
productivity, punctuality,
lower medical
adherence for drugs
that are sort of even very
high stakes drugs that
are lifesaving.
There's some evidence of
food and drug consumptions
in terms of healthy
eating or excessive drug
use and the like.
All of those things tend to be
correlated one way or the other
with different forms
of income or poverty.
So now you might say, well
that's interesting, but now
what explains these behaviors?
How do we think about this?
What [AUDIO OUT] plausible
explanation kinds
of autocorrelations.
To be very clear, these
are correlations, not
causal effects.
So education could explain
quite a few of those things.
It could explain
potentially productivity
and it could explain
potentially parenting
and it could explain some
form of financial investments.
It could also explain things
like medical insurance.
For example, if you look
at in some settings where
people have not sort
of learned in school
any basics of medicine or
biology and so on and sort of
and it's not obvious that
you should take medicine
from a traditional doctor
versus from some healer
in the village, because how
would you know what's better
and what's worse.
And sort of presumably
some of these things
you would learn in school.
So one broad
explanatory factor is
sort of like, [INAUDIBLE]
variables if you want,
and one of them is
potentially education.
It's not about omitted variable.
This is about a treatment
effect of poverty itself.
And I'm going to be more
specific about that.
But essentially it's something
about being in poverty itself
affects people's behaviors.
So it causes them--
some of these outcomes,
some of these things
that we've seen here.
We'll talk about that in detail,
but that's exactly right.
In some ways, people
would say, even for--
if you take credit for
example, or for some things,
you probably can't explain.
But for high return
investment, you
would say, while
there's uncertainty
and there's a good chance
that there might be losses
at the end of the
day, and if you're
really close to
subsistence, you might not
want to invest in stocks,
because if a bad shock happens,
that's really bad.
So I think some
of that is right.
And punctuality, for
example, could also
be in some way uncertainty.
It's like you try to
take a bus to work
and the bus just
comes every hour,
and then sometimes it
comes a half an hour early
and sometimes it comes later.
And it's really hard to
be actually punctual.
Could just be some
people are not productive
and are just bad at doing stuff.
And therefore, they
become poor and then
they end up being
poor because of that.
So that's essentially,
I think, that we
covered pretty much everything.
So one is it could be sort of
environmental conditions, which
is transportation, it's really
hard to get to work on time,
or have the community
for two hours
and then you're really tired and
that makes you less productive.
Things like predatory
lending sort
of tricks you into lending.
There could some some things
about institutional structures,
which is to say, I told
you for example at MIT,
there's a default--
or at other places,
there's defaults
for people to save money.
And there's a default
to get health insurance.
And there's defaults for
all sorts of good behaviors,
like for vaccinations
and so on and so forth.
We are sort of essentially
pushed by society,
by the environmental
conditions that we
face into doing the right thing
or whatever good behaviors,
whatever you want to call it.
And so the poor might just
not have those things.
So for example,
having a bank account
might be like if you paid
daily or you can buy by trip.
The rickshaw drivers
that I was showing you
earlier in the semester,
they paid trip by trip
and then they'd pass
by the liquor stores,
essentially daily, and have
a bunch of cash on hand.
Well, that's much trickier to
sort of resist sometimes, since
if you were particularly
also prone to physical pain,
and then sort of to
use alcohol as a way
to deal with your physical pain.
As opposed to somebody who paid
monthly and half of the money
goes into the rent anyway and
then other expenses and so on,
which is much easier to manage.
So that's kind of broadly
I would summarize it
as environmental conditions.
Then there's selection
and omitted variables,
which is, I think Joseph
has mentioned education,
which is a very good one.
There's things
like intelligence,
talent, effort,
mistakes, and so on.
You might say, well, if you
are more prone-- if you're
less productive, for example, if
you're prone to making mistakes
and so on, well
that sort of leads
to worse outcomes and that
makes you end up being poor.
And that's really sort of
in some sense, a right wing
kind of view, that people are--
they should do whatever
they want to do
and if the end of being poor,
it's sort of their fault,
and so on.
That's of course not what
we're going to argue here.
What we're interested
in-- or what
I'm trying to argue [AUDIO OUT]
show you some evidence off this
that there's a treatment effect
of poverty itself potentially.
Which is to say that being poor
itself causes these behaviors.
And again, I'll show you
the evidence in two ways.
One is by inducing
thoughts about money,
essentially thinking about
can you pay school fees,
can pay your rent, can you get
groceries for your children,
are your children are going to
be hungry tonight, and so on.
These are all kind of
thoughts that invade
people's minds involuntarily.
And by doing so, they
capture people's attention.
And then since attention
overall is limited,
people have less attention
available for other things.
That's sort of one broad theory.
And I'll focus on
that mostly which
people refer to it under
the name of scarcity.
And then there's a bunch
of other aspects of poverty
as well that might be
competing with people's
cognitive function, their
attention, that tire them out.
They're just not sleeping
well, be in pain, being exposed
to pollution, environmental
pollution, noise pollution,
and so on, and so forth.
And so now what's the
underlying idea here?
Well again, the underlying
idea is that there
might be what's called--
people might want to call
it behavioral poverty trap.
And the broad line
of argument is
that poverty affects people's
cognition, decision making,
or productivity.
These factors in
turn then influence
people's future poverty,
because if you're not productive
and you can't save
money and so on,
you're going to be more
poor in the future.
And if those things
are going on,
there is essentially some form
of a vicious cycle going on,
which makes it difficult,
if not impossible,
for a person to become rich.
Now notice at the very least,
that will lower mobility.
Sometimes if you're poor and
you want to become richer,
you have got to deal
with a bunch of bad stuff
that happens to you every day.
But [INAUDIBLE] mobility is low,
[INAUDIBLE] might be actually
a trap.
It's just next to or actually
impossible to become richer,
because all these forces are too
strong to overcome for people.
So today I'm going to talk about
two broad lines of research.
I'm going to focus mostly
on the first one, which
is monetary concerns capture
people's cognitive function.
I'm going to talk a little bit
about other poverty-induced
deprivation of behaviors
which might have sort
of similar effects overall.
So now I want to do a
simple test with you.
So what I'd like
you to do is to--
sorry, one second.
I'm trying to-- give me a sec.
I'd like you to--
hold on one second.
One second.
All right.
Ready?
Don't write anything down.
Just try to remember it and
then try to recall it in a bit.
I'm going to start reading.
Bed, rest, dream, doze, snore,
slumber, blanket, snooze, wake,
nap, awake, tired.
OK, now please write down as
many words as you remember.
10 more seconds.
All right, so done.
So usually I would have people
raise their hands, which
is a little tricky.
But I'm going to just
read you the list of words
and you can nod to me--
I can see some of you, at least.
You can nod and
tell me whether you
remember the words that I read.
OK, I'm going to start.
Bed, rest-- pretty good--
dream, doze, snore-- no?
Slumber, sleep, blanket,
snooze, wake, nap, awake, tired.
So I know this is
making everybody sleepy
and want to take a nap.
Me, too.
So here's the list of words
that I asked you to remember.
Now one thing
that's kind of nice
[INAUDIBLE] most people
remembered quite a few things.
The majority, for
example, remembers
bed and so on and so forth.
Now what's quite interesting
about these words is
that while I remember--
I put all these
names up here, which
is-- these are the words
that I actually read.
Now one word that's actually
missing in this list
here is sleep.
And so you sort of--
I snuck this in here on--
this is why I had to go back.
It turns out I actually
didn't read the word sleep,
but quite a few of you
were nodding happily
when I asked you about sleep.
And what's the reason
why you remembered sleep?
So all of these words is like--
they all around sleep.
So it's really like sleep
should have been there.
It's kind of the
type of thing where
people would ask you, have you
been to the parity last week,
where people just assume-- where
essentially all of the friends
were there-- people just
assume that you were there,
as well, because you're
supposed to be there.
It's like sleep is supposed
to be in this list,
but we didn't put it there.
And this is what is
called false memory tests.
And there's quite a bit of work
on actually false memories.
And people's minds
essentially make up things.
In particular, stuff
that's sort of--
or where you have all
situations that you think
that should be the case.
You can do the same with man
and other lists and so on.
And now psychologists
have been doing studies
for the rich and the poor.
And so here's two lists.
One is about sort of
money-related stuff.
And one is about sort of just
anything that's related to,
I guess, man or
gender in some ways.
And they looked
at how many people
have certain false memory.
And what these studies
show is essentially
that when you take
this list for a man
and you do this with high
income and low income people,
the fraction who remember a man
wrongly is about 15% to 20%.
The fraction among the
poor who remember money
is similarly high.
Among the rich,
that's not the case.
Now why is that?
Well, it seems to be that for
the poor, when you read lists
like groceries,
expense, bill, gas, et
cetera, what they think
about is essentially,
how I'm going to pay for this.
And they think about money.
When for the rich,
Instead, when you say
groceries or whatever,
they think about what I'm
going to buy for dinner
and what are the nice
things I'm going to do.
And for them, this is
really not top of mind.
So this is essentially at
least one piece of evidence
that money captures the
minds of the poor moreso
than for the rich.
Now, a second study is a study
about the doctor's visit.
So this is a study where
the participants were
asked about the following
situation, which
is imagine that you have
been feeling sick lately
and finally decided to
go see a doctor about it.
The doctor explains that you
have a serious condition that
requires immediate attention.
The good news, however, is
you are virtually guaranteed
to make a full recovery.
The doctor writes
several prescriptions.
You will also need to
make several appointments.
What would be on your
mind or how would you feel
about when you hear this news?
What are the three things
that you think about it?
Or you can think about
for a second what
is it that you would feel,
and what are you thinking
about when you see this.
And what's particularly
interesting
is how when you look
at people's responses
some people say
wife, son, co-worker.
Some people are scared, afraid,
worried, relief, hope, joy,
so like emotions or just of
relationships and other people.
Not exactly sure what the
co-workers doing there
but anyway, but what's
particularly interesting
is the fraction of
people who say costs.
And as you can imagine, when you
do this by low and high income
when you think about medical
conditions for the rich,
this is much more about
emotions about their health,
about their relationships,
their loved ones, and so on.
And when the poor think about
health or health expenditures
or health issues,
they think very much
about health expenditures,
and that is essentially
what's top of mind for them.
And so again, when you split the
sample by low and high income
people, the poor have much
higher proportions of money
really good thoughts as reported
by these kinds of questions
compared to the rich.
The third study-- the last
thing I'm going to show you
is the study that
I showed you very
much at the beginning of the
class, which was a study about
imagine you are about to
purchase an iPad for $500.
The salesman says you can get
the same iPad, exact same iPad
for $15 off.
Would you walk for 30
minutes in total for $15.
Would you go for
the other store?
And similarly, you'd
have to do the same thing
for an iPad case.
And so the result that
we found in this class
and like the other
studies have found
is that people are way
more likely to report
that they would walk for the
iPad than for the iPad itself.
And the explanation,
of course, is
that people evaluate things
in relative terms, right.
So if you think
about the iPad case,
$15 is really high
relative to like
$30 in the iPad cases of value,
while for the iPad itself,
$15 compared to $500
is not very much.
Now that's some form
of money illusion
or some form of community
confusion or the like,
because at the
end of the day you
should just be willing to walk
for 30 minutes for either $15
or not.
That's not going to change
depending on whether you
buy an iPad or an iPad case.
Now many studies have
found the kind of patterns
including like in this
class, but once you
do that with the poor,
they're much less
likely if at all to engage in
this kind of behavior, which
seems to suggest that
the poor, in fact,
are less prone to this, kind
of, labeling or, sort of,
like monetary sort
of comparisions.
For them essentially
$1 is $1 and they,
sort of, understand
that, like, $15
is valuable regardless of what
is surrounding comparisons
like.
And so if I have to summarize
what I've just shown
you very quickly is that
thoughts about money
tend to capture or take much
more space in the poor's minds
instead of the first two
studies that I showed you,
and second, the
extra focus on money
has actually some positive
consequences in some sense.
In some sense, you can say here
this is an irrational decision
to say, yes, that you
will go for the iPad case
compared to the iPad or some
of this optimization going on.
So the poor are actually
doing better or the less prone
to these kinds of errors
compared to the rich.
I think that's a good
thing for like potentially
better monetary decisions here.
So there's some
positive consequences
for impacts based on that.
now, and this is where
we're going to go, is,
well, are there also some
negative effects potentially?
The reason being that if
you have a certain amount
of attention available
overall, or cognitive resources
available, if your
brain is taken up
by essentially these
thoughts about money,
then there will be less
available resources
for other stuff.
Any questions on this so far?
OK, so then let's talk about
the scarcity work specifically.
So scarcity is actually
defined generally here
as not having
enough of something.
This could be money, friends,
hair, time, et cetera.
It's very general, actually.
And so the idea is
just like if you
have something that you
think you don't have enough.
Notice that the definition is
pretty vague in the sense that
like it's not just saying
like having low income,
but it's sort of
thinking that you
don't have enough income,
which could be also
like in relative
terms and so on.
And then the hypothesis
is that scarcity captured
people's mental cognitive
capacity, their bandwidth,
as they call it.
This happens automatically
and not intentionally.
That is to say, that
it's not people choosing
to spend a lot of time
on thinking about money,
but rather, money
captures their minds,
and then they have trouble
thinking about other things.
Think about this
as like, it would
be like suppose you
have like some fights
with a good friend of yours,
or a partner or the like,
and then you have an
important job interview.
It's really not
productive to think
about the fight with your
friend or family member
or partner or the like.
During the job
interview, there's
nothing productive
about doing that.
You should be focusing
on the interview
and try to do your best.
But it might be that like
essentially, these thoughts
invade your minds and
you sort of get really
distracted
unintentionally, and then
do worse in those kinds of--
And that's the idea
here similarly here
as well, which is that
essentially, there
might be some benefit of
figuring out monetary problems
and figuring out how to pay the
bills and so on and so forth.
But overall, these
benefits might
be overwhelmed by taking
over people's brain
that leaves less resources for
other things, the decisions
or productivity that
people have to do in life.
And so in particular,
poverty now, so this
is a general introduction.
Poverty specifically makes
monetary concerns top of mind,
so the poor might be acting
more rational in some ways,
in some sense, in
financial choices, which
is kind of what the evidence
that I just showed you
in there, several studies
that try to make that point.
But you know, scarcity might
then deteriorate performance
at other cognitive tasks.
Now, here's sort of a
PowerPoint version of that,
which, you know,
people may think
about many things in life.
They might think about rent.
They might think about
the kids doing well,
eating healthy, utilities,
car payments, and so on.
But what does scarcity do?
It magnifies,
essentially, people's
thoughts about rent, car
payments and utility bills.
These are all monetary things
that people think about a lot,
and thn it might sort of
like drown out or like force
out other thoughts about other
things, about eating healthy
or about taking care of
the kids in other ways
than paying the bills, OK.
And so now, I'm
going to show you
evidence of two studies that
sort of support this point.
The first one, the
paper is called
"Poverty impedes
cognitive function."
That was the reading for today.
The first one is
called the mall study.
So what does this mall study do?
It's kind of like
a lab experiment,
but it's sort of in some
sense like a field experiment.
So it's a major Jersey mall that
asks shoppers or stops shoppers
with a median household
income of roughly $70,000,
so sort of richer than
the average American,
but with quite a bit of
range of income overall.
So there's like very rich
people and fairly poor people.
And then there's a sequence
of three events, essentially,
which is, people are asked
hypothetical questions
involving money.
Some are hard and some are easy.
And then people are asked
to do cognitive tests,
a non-verbal test that
sort of measures people's
fluid intelligence, which
is Raven's Matrices, which
you might be familiar with.
They're sort of IQ type tests.
And some form of
cognitive control,
which essentially
is about like, are
you able to overwrite
automatic responses when
doing cognitive tasks.
And then number three, then,
is like people that answer
the hypothetical questions.
So what does this look like?
A hypothetical
question is involving
money, which is the following.
Your car is having some
trouble and requires x dollars
to be fixed.
You can pay in full, take
a loan or take a chance
and forgo the service
at the moment.
How would you go about
making this decision?
And so then, people ask
this question and they say,
well, you can think
about this for a while.
And afterwards, I'm
going to ask you
about the answer
to that question.
And then there's a hard
version and an easy version.
The idea is that the experiment
wants to keep everything
the same for like
across treatments,
and the idea is that $150
for the average American
is not that much
money, so it's not
going to be a huge
problem for most people,
at least in normal
times of their lives.
But $1,500 is actually a lot
of money for like a low income
person in the US,
but perhaps not
that big of a deal
for a rich person.
Like for a rich person, the
$1,500 or $150 are both fine.
They're going to have some
money in the bank account,
and they're going to
deal with it somehow.
It's not a huge issue.
For the poor person, $150 is not
great, but not a huge problem
or not a huge headache.
But $1,500 surely is really bad.
That's sort of the
idea here, right.
Now what the study that
finds is that-- and let
me walk you through
these graphs.
Let's look on the left side.
On the right side
is quite similar.
You'll see here
always four bars.
The dark bars are how people
are doing after the hard task,
and the lighter bars
after the easy task.
Let's start with
the light gray bars,
comparing the poor
versus the rich.
And what you essentially
see is the poor
and the rich are doing
pretty much the same
after doing the easy task.
But to be clear,
what's poor versus rich
is essentially being split
by the median income.
So if you're above the
median, you're called rich.
If you're below
the median, you're
called poor for the
purpose of this study.
Now, for the easy
task here, this
is like the rich do
essentially as well or as badly
as the poor do.
They get about 40% correct
in these Raven's puzzles,
and the poor do
essentially the same.
So there's no difference
after the easy task.
Now, after the hard
task, for the rich,
essentially it's the same.
If anything, they do
a little bit better.
The difference is not
statistically significant.
In contrast, you see like
a clear drop in performance
among the poor, OK.
They do about like 12
percentage points worse.
This is really like a huge
difference in how well people--
so this is for Raven's Matrices.
This is for what's
called hearts and flowers
for cognitive control,
which is essentially
how good are people at
controlling their attention
or resources.
And what you see is
essentially more or less
the same pattern, that
for the easy task,
the rich and the poor
do pretty much the same.
The hard task compared
to the easy task
does nothing for the rich.
This is actually,
the performance
is the same or
slightly different
but not statistically
significantly so.
For the poor, there is a
large drop in performance
compared to the rich.
Any questions on that?
OK, So then I'm going to show
you the second study that's
related to this.
So one thing you
might sort of say,
well, we're going to show
you, already, a study, so why
do we need another study
when we already did one.
We showed you that like poverty
and thinking about poverty
affects people's cognition, so
why do we need more evidence. .
So effort is an
interesting issue that--
so there's, in fact,
this study has--
and I took this out of the
slides because I had too many.
There's an incentivized
version of this task.
And the authors
do find that, even
once you incentivize
these tasks,
we find the same patterns.
But even there, it's a bit
sort of like a task that
is not a task that people
do in their real life.
And in a way, which is actually
not what the harvest study is
addressing, you might wonder.
Does this translate into real
world choices and decisions
that actually have consequence
for people's behaviors?
To be clear, these effects
here, these differences
in cognitive performances,
are very large.
This is like the order of
magnitude something like 10 IQ
points, which is really huge.
So you might sort of argue that
we think that IQ, et cetera,
matters a lot.
So in some sense, that's
what Mullainathan and Shafir
would argue.
But, no, I agree with you.
In some sense, we would
like to see does this
translate into
real world choices
that we see in people's
everyday lives.
Now, I think we talked
about a few of those things.
So one is external
validity concerns,
which is to say, look, we did
this study in the mall, which
is a little bit of
a funny thing to do.
And you hear about the
scenario, which is kind of weird
and maybe tricks you out.
And maybe the poor
are more freaked out
than the rich for some reason.
But really, if you
think about paying back
your debt or any sort of school
fees or just not having money,
that's a repeated
exposure of something
that know in your real life.
For example, not having
harvest versus harvest
is a thing that you experience
every year or every twice
a year even.
And so you think
some of these things
might sort of go away
with repeat exposure.
And so we kind of would like to
have a real world setting where
we have actually real
world natural variation
or sort of experimental
variation potentially as
opposed to the somewhat weird
feature in some mall somebody
talks you up and asks you some
questions, which people might
find funny and might not be
representative for what people
do with their lives.
And then the second
part is kind of how do
we interpret magnitudes, right?
So I showed up and said, look,
these effects are really large.
After the hard task, the
poor do worse than the rich.
But we have no
idea how we should
scale this in terms of
what does it actually mean
for actual effects of poverty.
Suppose I give somebody
$1,000 or $10,000,
what does it do to
people's performance?
It essentially,
what this shows, is
that the poor are
more sort of frazzled
by these financial questions.
But it gives you
essentially-- and that
seems to be important
because the magnitude is
large and these effects.
But there's no way to
actually scale these effects
in some sense in thinking
about what is this priming
intervention actually correspond
to in the real world in terms
of dollars and how rich
or poor people are.
So that's another
sort of reason why you
might want to do another study.
OK.
So what is the other study?
As Lauren was
already saying, it's
a study with 464
sugarcane farmers
in 54 villages in Tamil Nadu.
These are small
scale farmers that
earn at least the majority of
60% of income from sugarcane.
So these are mostly
sugarcane farmers.
And crucially for the
study, the harvest
is staggered over
a three to five
month period set by the
sugar mills due to capacity
constraints.
So it's not some people
harvest earlier than others
because they decide to
do so maybe because they
need more cash.
But it's rather because
of capacity constraints.
The sugar mill is essentially
deciding who to harvests early
and who harvests late.
And so, now, what
this study explored
is that the sugarcane harvest
cycle takes about 18 months.
It's extremely long.
And as a result, farmers tend to
be relatively poor pre-harvest.
Think of that this is like grad
school and undergrad stipends.
If you have that
money for the month
or the semester or the like,
the beginning of the semester
is always amazing--
or month, for that
matter, is always amazing.
You have lots of cash.
And you can do lots
of nice things.
And then towards the end
of the month or semester,
people tend to run
out of cash, at least
when I was a grad student
or student in general.
Similar things are
true for food stamps
or other sort of cash programs.
There's quite a bit of
evidence that shows,
at the beginning of
the month, people
are doing a lot better
than at the end, which
seems to suggest that people
have trouble smoothing
their income over
time, which presumably
has to do with some form of
self-control or other problems.
But so for the
purpose of this study,
farmers are relatively
poor pre-harvest.
And that now allows
the authors to look
at within person
comparisons of people,
sometimes when they're poor and
sometimes when they're rich,
at looking at the
cognitive performance,
by looking at people
pre and post harvest.
Now, first, you want to
kind of see some evidence
that farmers' financial
situation is actually
worse pre-harvest.
And so there's quite a few--
and you can focus on
the first column here--
pieces of evidence.
People are more likely to
have their belongings pawned.
They're more likely to
have loans outstanding.
They also have more
loans outstanding.
They're also more likely to say
yes to the question or higher
scores to the question
about their ability
to cope with ordinary bills in
the past 15 days post-harvest.
And so all of these things sort
of are saying, essentially,
before harvest, farmers are in
a financially tricky situation.
And after harvest, that gets
better because they get,
essentially, a bunch of
cash from this harvest.
Because, essentially,
it's a cash crop.
You sell your sugarcane, and
then you get a bunch of money
that you can use over
the next 18 months.
Now, then the authors find,
again, using Raven's matrices
and some measures of
cognitive control,
that people are doing a lot
worse pre-harvest compared
to post-harvest.
In terms of Raven's
matrices, this is accurate.
Essentially, people
do better than getting
more Raven's matrices correct
compared to the control group.
They also are doing better in
terms of cognitive control.
Post-harvest response
times go down,
which is a good thing here.
And post-harvest,
also, people's errors
go down in these measures.
And there's a lot of
detail related to that.
But in some sense, that doesn't
matter much for you right now.
People, essentially, are
doing better post-harvest
when they have more cash.
Now, what confounds
can you think about?
What are potential
problems with this result?
Actually, this is
consistent with poverty
impeding cognitive
function, but there
could be other things going on.
And what are these other things?
I think there's
some good evidence--
or one good thing
is that it would
have to be a very specific shock
that has to do with harvest.
Because, essentially,
the harvest period
was staggered over
several months.
So it's not like, at
some point, the weather
got worse or the
weather got better.
Because some people actually
harvest earlier than others,
and there's a
pre-post comparison.
But there could be other stuff,
time trends or something,
going on at least in some ways.
In a way, I think a
confound or, in a way,
it's also just a
different interpretation
perhaps in some ways
in the sense of saying,
well, it's not just worries
about the level of income.
But it's also worries about,
essentially, risk or anxiety,
essentially.
And so that's
slightly different,
but the anxiety could
also sort of capture
people's minds in some ways.
Of course, then you would
want to see something,
like maybe that's
worse for the rich
compared to the poor
or things like that.
But that's exactly right.
So there could be
essentially labor costs
or any sort of other
distractions related
to the harvest, which--
this is kind of related to
what [INAUDIBLE] was saying,
which is the
harvest itself might
have these kinds of effects.
OK, I think we mentioned
most of the things
that I have on my list.
So there's first one is
calorie consumption, which
is sort of the typical thing
that development economists can
study a lot, which is
to say, poor nutrition
might make people do worse.
It's bad for attention.
We talked a little bit about
shopping on a hungry stomach,
but also think about doing tests
or exams on an empty stomach
is probably not a good idea.
The author's have some evidence
that the food expenditures are
pretty similar pre and post high
harvest from some other sample.
Overall, malnutrition
doesn't seem
to be a huge issue in this area.
Having said that,
I think it's also
reasonable to think that pre and
post harvest you should have,
actually, more money.
And then you've got to spend
the money on something.
And presumably, some of
that would go on food.
So the authors argue that
nutrition is not a big issue.
Then there's sort of
two broad issues, which
I think was Joseph and
Katherine's comments, which
is about the uncertainty
of the harvest size
and some issues related
to labor effort.
And so, here, the authors
have some evidence
from post-harvest
pre-payment sample.
What does that mean?
This is a sample
that these are people
who have harvested already,
so they have already
exerted the labor effort.
And they also know already
their approximate payment.
And-- sorry.
I was getting confused by this.
So these are people who have
already done their harvest.
They have done all
the work already.
They know already what the
harvest size will be like.
But those people,
essentially, are still
not doing better compared
to the people who
have received their cash.
So that essentially
is to say, even
once you have done all
the effort and so on,
that doesn't seem to help in
a sense of you're fully doing,
you're not exhausted
from the work already.
You already have all
your harvest there.
You already know how
big your harvest is,
but you haven't really
received the money yet.
And you know already
what the harvest size is.
It can't really be about
anxiety of the harvest size.
Yet if you compare those
people to the people that
received the money,
you saw few differences
between those people
and the people
who have done
already the harvest.
And so that argues
that essentially it's
not about anxiety, per se,
about the harvest size,
but rather about
just having money
in your pocket versus not.
Let me see what the--
is this the correct graph?
I see.
So this is a little bit
misleadingly labeled.
What this is supposed
to say is this
is post-harvest and pre-harvest.
But what they mean by
post-harvest and pre-harvest,
post-harvest is
meant by you have
received the cash versus not.
But both of these are actually
both post-harvest in the sense
that they have done
already the work.
Anyway, sorry, that's
a bit confusing.
But essentially, what
they're trying to say
is essentially
what really matters
is not the work around
the harvest, per se,
or the uncertainty
around the harvest.
It's really about receiving
the cash versus not.
And then there's
another problem,
which you haven't
really brought up
which is the issue of
learning effects, right?
When people do the
task several times,
presumably when you
do a test twice,
you're going to do better.
But to address this issue,
they also have what's
called a hold-out
sample that takes
the cognitive tests for the
first time post-harvest.
So what I showed you before
was proposed for both people
that have both of these tests.
There are some samples
that's only done
the task once post-harvest.
And they don't perform
worse than people
who do the task for the second
time, which seems to say
it's not really about learning.
Having said that,
that is essentially
only a small subsample.
Comparison really seems
mostly underpowered.
And there are some concerns,
surely, about still effects.
Any questions on these?
OK.
So this is a study
from a few years ago.
So then what kind of follow
up is there that sort
of considers further evidence?
So there's one very nice
study by Carvalho et al.
in 2015 that looks at
the same issue in the US.
And they looked at cognition
and decision making of US
households around paydays.
And essentially, they find no
cognitive effects whatsoever.
They also find no
effects of decision
making as one would
have expected.
It raises the question
about what's going on here.
And [INAUDIBLE] what's going on.
So it could be that this
is an external validity
issue in some sense.
In a sense, really
what is needed here
is really extreme
poverty and really
large differences in people's
income or the amount of money
that they have available.
And when you look at
US households, at least
the households that were
considered in the Carvalho
study about payday,
well, there's
differences in how
much money they have,
cash on hand they have.
The difference is
actually not that huge.
And so that might just be
not sufficiently [INAUDIBLE]
around those paydays
to be able to generate
those type of effects.
It could also be that
these effects don't really
replicate in a sense of it's
a replicability issue, which
could be a concern as well.
There's a nice study--
and this gets to the issue
that I think Joseph
mentioned, which
is a study by Lichand and Mani
looking at drought insurance.
And what they essentially
argue is that,
when you [? provide ?]
[? people with ?] insurance--
so usually insurance, or
people would argue, is useful.
If a bad state
happens in the world,
you can essentially get--
might get a payment, right?
If I get some health shock or if
my harvest is bad or the like,
I get some money from
the insurance company.
And that is good.
Because in the bad state,
the marginal utility
is really high of
receiving money.
And so if I am willing to
pay for insurance right now,
in the future receiving-- so
I'm willing to pay for insurance
now.
Because in the future, in
a bad state of the world,
I value that money more than
in a good state of the world.
So in a good state [INAUDIBLE]
willing to pay for insurance.
Now, what Lichand and Mani
are instead arguing is,
well, there's an
additional value
of insurance, which
essentially it's
helping reduce their anxiety
and worries about money ex ante
in all states of the world.
That is to say, if I'm really
worried about bad harvest
shocks or other stuff,
health stocks happening
in the future, that might
really frazzle me and really
sort of worry you all the time,
which in turn might affect
people's cognitive performance.
Well, that's in all
states of the world.
Even when you're
doing well right now,
even if nothing
bad ever happens,
you're going to do worse
today because you're
worried about these things.
And sort of providing
insurance, therefore,
might help people better even
in good states of the world
or in all states of
the world in addition
to sort of having the insurance
value of helping people
in that state of the world.
Well, they have
some evidence of it.
There is some mixed
evidence overall.
But I think the
idea of insurance
being helpful for the
poor, for anybody, not just
because it helps in
bad states, but it
helps people worry
about bad states,
is a very nice
one that hopefully
will be explored further.
Now, then another question that
I think Jose was bringing up
is to say, well, there
are these cognitive tasks.
Well, I showed you
so far that there
are these tasks and Raven's
matrices and cognitive control.
And sort of, arguably, IQ tests
are important then and helpful.
And we think that's helpful
and maps to something
useful for the world.
But it's a little
bit hard to tell.
Does this actually
matter for income?
Is this really important
or not important?
And how much does it--
so in a paper with
[INAUDIBLE] we
looked at this in
a field setting
where the workers in Orissa
and rural areas in India.
And what we did there
is we hired people
for about two weeks to do a
simple labor cast where they
were doing leaf plates, so
essentially putting together
leafs into plates, which are
sort of used in many settings,
by stitching them together
using little wooden sticks.
And so people are
hired for two weeks.
And then for the
sample, we varied.
Some people were paid
earlier, and some people
were paid later.
So everybody was paid
exactly the same,
conditional on showing up and
conditional on how much they
produced.
So their piece rates, how much
they were paid, were the same.
And their attendance
paid for showing up.
The only difference was that
some people were paid earlier,
and some people were paid later.
So that allows us then look at
how do people, the same people,
how would they perform
when they're paid already
versus not, compared to another
group that is essentially
only paid later.
And this is a period
in the lean period
when people are extremely
financially constrained.
So people are really
short on cash.
And you can look,
essentially, really
at the impact of
transfers or cash
constraints in this setting.
What we find is a
relatively clear evidence
that paying people early makes
people a lot more productive.
And moreover, these
effects are the largest
for the poorest workers.
So essentially, when you sort
of divide the sample in two,
along the people who are richer
and poorer to start with,
people who are particularly
poor have the largest impacts
in the sample.
And this have sort of
pretty large effects.
It's about 5% to 10%
of the productivity,
which is doesn't sound that
large in absolute terms.
But in relative
terms or in terms
of when you double
people's wages,
people's earnings go up only
as much or not much more.
So really increasing
people's productivity
is very, very hard
in these settings.
And relatively
minor interventions,
such as the one that we did,
had pretty large effects
in the real world setting for
people for whom this is really
their real jobs in their real
life for about two weeks.
So suppose you hired
somebody for a year.
Should you pay them daily,
weekly, monthly, or what?
And so what I'm arguing or
what our evidence shows,
that when you hire people for
two weeks, paying people twice,
as in paying people once
after a week and then the rest
at the end, makes
workers more productive
than paying workers
only at the very end.
And assuming, you know,
depending on the interest
rate-- but that seems to be a
thing the company should do.
But of course, if you
hire people for a year,
then paying people weekly
versus monthly or biweekly,
the comparison becomes
quite different.
Because essentially, the
control group, that's
paid after two weeks.
Now, after two weeks,
of course, they
have a lot more money
because they haven't spent it
compared to the treatment
group who's paid earlier.
And I think there, essentially,
we can't really speak to that.
In some sense, our design is
not really set up to do this.
You would have to do at
least another week or two
to measure how is the
control group now doing
compared to the treatment
group or do it repeatedly.
And there might also be
some effects on over time,
repeatedly, some
of these effects
might be going away
because workers learn
and so on and so forth.
I think of this evidence much
more as a proof of concept
that, A, providing cash or
alleviating cash constraints
among workers, either through
some low interest rate
loans or some early payments
or some form of UBI or cash
transfers, unconditional or
conditional cash transfers,
essentially improving
workers financial situation
in some ways, can be
productive for firms.
Now, how the firm then
actually does that
we don't necessarily know.
And this is sort of
too small, short,
of an experiment to show that.
But it's sort of proof of
concept that, in a real world
setting with very high
stakes for workers--
this is their real earnings--
there seem to be these effects.
So for firms, it
might be, well, do
they have to, in
fact, try to improve
their financial
situation [INAUDIBLE]..
Or for governments, it
might be valuable to think
about cash transfers as
a way to do-- so usually,
when you think about
cash transfers-- so let
me actually just talk
about this for a second.
And then we can talk about
other confounds of the study.
So usually, when you think about
the public debate about cash
transfers and about sort of
welfare programs for the poor,
often sort of the
right-wing response is,
well, aren't the poor
going to be lazy?
And they're not going to work.
And then what about effort
and so on and so forth?
And they get used to the money.
And then don't work
hard enough eventually.
Well, the evidence that
we have here in our paper
seems to say, in
fact, the opposite.
That is to say workers,
when you alleviate
their financial constraints,
when you give them cash,
they become more productive.
And they work harder
than otherwise.
Granted, we don't have
any labor supply response.
What I'm showing you here is
essentially productivity, which
is how hard a worker's working
or how much work a worker is
producing per hour worked.
But I think similar things could
be true for cash transfers.
And there's some quite
interesting evidence
on cash transfer programs.
So both cash transfer
and, in particular,
what's called ultra-poor
programs, which
are sort of these
multi-faceted asset programs,
leads to large and sustained
increases in asset, savings,
consumptions, et cetera.
That is to say, once you provide
people with financial resources
when they're very poor,
not only do they better
in the short run.
But in the case of the
ultra-poor programs,
in the long run three
to five years later,
people are doing better in
terms of having more assets,
saving more, consuming
more, and so on.
And that seems to say that
there might be an issue going on
and some form of a
poverty trap going on.
And somewhere of the
underlying potential channels
might be things like scarcity,
stress, mental health, and so
on.
We're going to talk a little bit
about mental health and stress
in a second.
But essentially, if there are
these types of effects going on
for the government or any
other sort of public policy,
these kinds of programs,
conditional cash transfers,
in addition to having the
advantage of improving people's
well-being and having the high
marginal utility of money when
they're very poor, it
might also, in addition,
make people more
productive as opposed
to a working less or the like.
So I think those
two things, I think,
are sort of the takeaways.
If one wanted to understand
optimal pay structures,
one would have to do longer
run types of experiments,
as Natalie pointed out.
So essentially, the way
we set this up is we
essentially pay people--
sorry.
This is my Slack making noise--
pay people to--
sorry, [INAUDIBLE]----
people through the employer.
Essentially, we said, OK,
the employer is paying, now,
earlier versus later.
And naturally, then the worker
might just [INAUDIBLE] happier
or doing better financially, but
also like the employer better
and saying, look, you
just paid me early.
I now trust you more
that you're going
to be paying me in the future.
Maybe that's some
form of gift giving
or reciprocity, again, sort of
happy about things, [INAUDIBLE]
work harder to make
the employer happy.
There are several
things to get at this.
And the most important
part, perhaps, you also
have that we announced
essentially the structure
a few days before the
actual payment is made.
That is to say, on day five, we
announce and say, on the 8th,
you're going to be paid
versus we don't announce it.
We say you're going
to be paid only
later at the end of the study.
And so if you think this is
about reciprocity or feelings
towards the employer, you
would think that then workers
should then already
be working harder
once they hear about when they
get these kind of announcement
effects.
And it seems to be
the case that there's
essentially no announcement
effect whatsoever.
Workers only become productive
pretty much precisely
once they receive
their cash on hand,
which is very much
consistent with what
I showed you earlier, the
results from Mani et al.,
in their study.
It seems to really be the case
that knowing that somebody will
be paid is really not helping
workers or making workers
more productive both in the
form of their relationship
or due to their relationship
with the employer,
but also due to other effects,
including perhaps their worries
or concerns that they might
have about [INAUDIBLE]
So it seems to be that
similarly from the Mani et al.
paper, when workers
have done their harvest
and you have the
harvest in front of you
and it's worth so
many rupees, that
doesn't seem to increase
their cognitive scores.
That's what I was
showing you earlier.
Really what it seems to be is
you have to be actually paid.
So once workers actually
have the cash in hand, only
then their cognitive
function goes up.
There seems to be
something [INAUDIBLE]
about this [INAUDIBLE] example
I have for you is suppose
you have to pay your bills.
Suppose you don't
have enough money.
And then, on the
first of the month,
you're going to be paid
your stipend or whatever
as a student.
There's something distinctly
different from having actually
been paid the money
on your bank account
than having it in
your possession
that is yours or being
sent a check or whatever,
as opposed to knowing it's
going to come in two days
and you have your
outstanding credit card bills
even if you know that
you can pay them.
That's, in some sense,
from introspection,
the best example I have for you.
But it seems to be--
and you're right.
In some sense, there
could have been
some effect of just telling
workers you're going
to be paid early versus later.
But it doesn't seem
to be the case.
This really seems to be
the case of receiving
the money, having
cash in hand, and then
being able to pay
the money lender
or pay essentially some
person that you owe
money, some money back,
seems to be what's
quite important for generating
those kinds of effects OK
so let's move on
I already talked about this.
Essentially, yeah,
so there seems
to be these large
effects of ultra
poor programs, which
seem to say that there
might be some underlying
behavioral or other poverty
trap going on.
And sort of we don't
have the answer to that,
but one hypothesis is that some
of the underlying psychological
issues might be
responsible for that.
Now, what are other poverty
induced deprivation?
So poverty entails a bunch
of different deprivations
beyond money, including
malnutrition, high levels
of stress, sleep deprivation.
People's sleeping conditions
tend to be terrible.
Noise pollution, the poor are
more disproportionately exposed
to noise.
There's environmental
pollution, in particular air,
that the poor are
much more exposed to.
Heat, the poor often
don't have access
to heat and/or temperature
more generally.
The poor are more exposed
to high temperature
and don't have
access to ACs often.
There is also some form
of stigma and exclusion,
which might have certain
cognitive and other effects.
There's some evidence of
disproportionate substance
abuse.
I've shown you some evidence of
increased excessive drinking.
And there's also quite
a bit of evidence
of increased mental illness,
especially among the poor.
So within any given
location, the poor
are disproportionately
affected by mental illness,
including things like
depression and anxiety.
But there's a bunch of
research in other settings
that shows that each of these
factors affect either health
and/or cognitive function.
And so you might wonder how are
these factors then affecting
people's decision
making and choices.
And just to give you
some example of this,
this is some work that
we have done in Chennai.
So to give some sense
of what this looks like,
the poor essentially tend to
have very, very challenging
sleeping conditions.
There's dust, noise, mosquitoes.
People sleep in the same room.
People sleep outside in
the middle of the street.
And it's hot.
There's people
sleeping on the floor.
So essentially, any
challenging sleeping conditions
that you can think of you can
find it among the urban poor.
And so one question
you might ask is,
well, then does this
lack of good sleep affect
people's capacity to work
and their decision making?
And so in our study,
what we do is we
objectively measure sleep
quantity and quality
in Chennai.
And we document severe
sleep deprivation
and alarmingly low quality
of sleep in is setting.
What do I mean by this?
People sleep on average
about 6.5 hours per night.
And the quality of
this sleep is low,
which one measurement of that
is their fraction of time
that they sleep along the
time that they spend in bed
is about 70%.
That's what's referred
to as sleep efficiency.
Sleep efficiency is way
higher in rich countries.
It's about 85% to 90%.
So if the rich spend an hour
in bed, they spend about 55
or something minutes asleep.
If the poor do that, it's
about 40 something minutes.
So essentially, there's
lots of awakenings.
And as a consequence,
in our sample,
people seem about 5 and
1/2 hours per night.
Now, then what we do is
we have two interventions
to increase sleep
and provide people
information, sleep devices,
which is mattress, ear
plugs, eye shields, and so on.
And we increased sleep by quite
a bit for about three weeks.
And in this experiment, we
also have an intervention
of a nap intervention
that offers people naps
at the office, which provides
high quantity and high quality
of sleep in that setting.
Now, what we find then
is, somewhat surprisingly,
that actually increasing
people's sleep
does very little.
So people sleep about 20 to
30 minutes more every night
for three weeks.
And we measure the labor supply.
We hire them for
about that time.
People are not doing better
in any way in terms of people
not working more.
People are not more productive.
People are not doing
better in cognitive tasks.
They're not happier
and so on and so forth.
They also don't make
different decisions.
And if anything, you know, they
decrease their labor supply.
They actually work fewer hours.
Why is that?
Well, because people are
spending so much more
time in bed, they have now less
time available during the day.
And some of that time goes
into working fewer hours.
Now, in contrast,
the nap treatment
has pretty large effects on
the productivity, attention,
well-being, patience, and so on.
So it's not sleep cannot affect
people's outcomes in these
settings.
But rather, a night
sleep, as it is
does not really do very much, at
least the type of night's sleep
that people are getting.
And so what we then provide
some evidence of that what's
really important
here or the reason
why people's sleep
does not do very much
in increasing their productivity
or improving their outcomes
is because the quality
of sleep is so low.
So let me sort of
look at the sample
and look at people who sleep
better and worse at baseline
at the beginning of the study.
People who sleep better at
the beginning of the study,
they actually tend to have
reasonably large effects
on their productivity.
In contrast, people
who have bad sleep
to start with, for them,
essentially increasing
their sleep does nothing and
potentially makes things worse.
So what did we learn?
I do not want you to take
away that sleeping does not
do anything.
MIT students are
chronically undersleeping.
And you could be probably
sleeping more, all of you,
or most of you.
Essentially, what
we learn from this
is that, when people's sleep
conditions are really terrible,
well, then increasing
one's sleep actually
doesn't do very much.
The return on sleeping
is just very, very low.
And so what we
learn, in some ways,
that the poor, at
least in this setting,
are actually doing as well as
they could, in a sense of they
do the best they can.
And since sleep is so bad, is
so terrible, people sleep really
badly, increasing their
sleep does not do very much.
That's not to say, if you
actually fix their sleeping
conditions, if you put
everybody into a nice hotel
or a nice bedroom or
give them a nice house
and help them sleep
better, that wouldn't
have potentially large effects.
But the study that we
conducted was not doing that.
The study that we
conducted was essentially
saying, take your sleep
conditions as given.
And look at what
happens when you
increase people's sleep duration
for given sleep quality.
And that doesn't do very much.
In contrast, as I
showed you or told you,
naps seem to be quite effective
in having a large number
or range of effects, which
seems to say that sleep can
potentially matter quite a bit.
But what really is important is
try to figure out how could we
perhaps increase people's
sleep quality which might
have then important effects.
Sorry, that was a lot of
information, more than
I perhaps intended.
Any questions on that?
OK, so then the
last piece, which
I'm going to just sort of
say a little bit about,
is a paper that we just
finished on the relationship
between poverty and
common mental disorders
as they're referred to, which
is anxiety and depression.
And what we there
sort of argue--
and it's a pretty short
paper if you're interested.
I'll, in fact, put it
on my website tonight.
We're looking at,
essentially, the relationship
between poverty and
these two conditions.
And what we do is, first,
we show the causal effect
in both directions.
And so there's quite a
bit of evidence that,
essentially, being poor is bad
for people's mental health.
And these are causal studies.
So for example, providing
people cash transfers
improves consistently
their mental health.
So there's a causal effective
from not having money
on people's mental health
and anxiety and depression.
At the same time,
there's a causal effect
of anxiety and depression
on people's ability
to earn income and,
thus, their poverty.
So for example, if you
provide people with CBT
or some other forms
of psychotherapy,
that reduces their depression.
And then, in turn, it
increases their labor supply,
which in turn presumably
increases their ability
to earn income.
So there's causal effects in
both directions from poverty
to common mental disorders and
from common mental disorders
to poverty.
And then what the paper does
in a lot more detail is then
think about what are
different mechanisms
for this causal relationship
and what exactly, what evidence,
do they actually have of that.
And so on the side from poverty
and from economic conditions
to mental health,
there's a number
of different issues that could
be quite important ranging
from stresses or just being
exposed to lots of shocks
and, therefore,
worries and uncertainty
to environmental conditions.
In particular,
there's quite a bit
of emerging evidence
of pollution
being bad for people's
mental health,
so essentially pollution
causing depression, for example.
There's some potential
for physical health,
just being in bad health.
It might be bad for your
mental health in part
because it causes physical
pain and other illnesses.
There's some evidence
of early life conditions
growing up in
poverty tends to be
bad for people's mental health.
And there's some nice
evidence of shocks
to mothers' and fathers' income
might cause mental illness much
later in life for the children.
There's quite a bit of evidence
of trauma, violence, and crime,
which the poor are
disproportionately
exposed to, affecting
people's mental health.
And finally, social status,
shame, and isolation,
if you sort of stigmatize
and isolate from society,
that might be bad for
your mental health.
Particular, sort of
relative comparisons
could be quite important.
And then at the
same time, there are
effects in the other
directions coming
from depression and anxiety.
So one profound way in which
depression and anxiety affect
people's behavior is cognitive
function, the way people think.
So in contrast to other
things such as health,
depression and anxiety
affect the way people think.
And then that might
affect people's beliefs,
their confidence,
overconfidence,
underconfidence,
belief updating,
all the stuff that we talked
about in the class as well
as their preferences, and time
preferences, risk preferences,
social preferences, and so on.
It might affect their labor
productivity, their labor
supply, how much people work,
and how productive they are.
Of course, people might be
very stigmatized and treated
badly because of mental illness,
which in addition sort of then
makes people less likely
to seek help potentially.
Because if you're
then stigmatized,
you might not want to
declare to your employer
or to anybody else
that you're depressed.
People tend to have worse health
conditions if they're depressed
or they suffer from mental
illness or other health
conditions tend to get
worse, health expenditures.
There's also some
evidence of depression
affecting women's empowerment.
I think there's two
potential channels here.
One is that women are, in fact,
disproportionately affected
by depression,
anxiety, and so on.
So the measured
prevalence is about twice
as high and sort of to
the extent that now,
if you improve
people's mental health,
women will disproportionately
benefit from that.
And then there's
evidence that, once you
do that, women have
higher bargaining
power in the household, more
say about resources spent
and so on and so forth.
And then finally,
potentially quite important
is effects on young people.
This ranges from primary
and secondary school
age to college
students and so on,
which is to say that a lot
of mental health conditions
appear during adolescence.
And so those are often when
very critical decisions are made
when it comes to education.
Do you drop out of school?
Do you go to college
and so on and so forth?
It turns out there's
actually quite not
a lot of causal
evidence on this,
but it seems very plausible that
this could be quite important.
And sort of taking
these things together,
it seems to be that poverty,
through various different
channels, including
scarcity, which I showed you
at the beginning,
but also including
all these other conditions
might affect profoundly
the [INAUDIBLE] and
how they make decisions
and how productive they are
at work, which then could
reinforced poverty
and make it harder
for people to become richer.
This is a lot of information.
So any questions?
I'm happy to discuss
or answer any questions
that you would have.
I'm not expecting you to
remember all of those things.
I was just more
elaborating for anybody
who might be interested.
You can also read all of
those things in the paper
that I'll add to the
course website as well.
All right, so on
Wednesday, we're
going to talk about
happiness and mental health.
Please read the paper
by Kahneman and Deaton.
Notice I just changed
this in the syllabus.
So if you have an old
version of the syllabus,
please make sure you
read the new paper.
I think it was very short, so
it shouldn't be tricky to read.
Essentially, it's looking
at what kinds of things
predict whether people
are happy or not.
And then on Monday, we're
going to talk about policy
with behavioral agents.
Just as a reminder,
we have a guest
at the end of class next time.
I hope the guests
will come at 2:20.
I'm hoping for a
lama to visit us,
but it could also be a goat.
We'll see how that goes.
Any questions or comments?
When it comes to
depression and anxiety,
specifically I'm going to
talk about it more generally.
So one of the things I'm
working on, for example,
is looking at the impact of
cognitive behavioral therapy
or other psychotherapies to
improve people's mental health
and then look at the effects
on people's beliefs, how
confident are they
in themselves,
how they update their beliefs.
And remember, we have this stuff
from [INAUDIBLE] and others
about asymmetric
belief updating and is
that affected, for example,
by people's mental health.
Moreover, we look
at preferences,
which is precisely
time preferences,
social preferences,
risk preferences.
And once you improve
people's depression,
does that affect people's time
social and risk preference?
More broadly, there's quite
a few people trying to do
studies-- and I'll run
through this fairly quickly--
to look at these types of
effects, which, for example,
there's some work
around malnutrition that
shows, once you provide
people with more calories,
there's some indications of
less discounting, which is kind
of what you're alluding to.
There's some work
on the relationship
between stress and discounting.
There's actually not much
evidence or less evidence
than you would expect.
For sleep deprivation,
for example, we find,
when people nap, they're
less present biased compared
to when they haven't napped.
For example, for
alcohol consumption,
I do find that people save more.
And it seems to be not
driven by having more money.
So again, that seems to be
consistent with people's time
preference in some way
affected by these conditions.
Overall, there's quite
a bit of evidence
so far on productivity.
So papers essentially show that,
when you're disproportionately
exposed to heat, people
are less productive.
People learn less.
When you're exposed to noise,
people are less productive.
When people have less
nutrition, they're
less productive and
so on and so forth.
There's less evidence, so far,
on decision making and sort
of preferences overall.
That's what people are
currently working on,
but that's exactly the question.
Can we sort of explained
potentially some of this stuff
that I was mentioning at the
very beginning of the lecture?
Can we explain potentially
certain behavioral biases
or certain deviations from
the neoclassical model
by alleviating or addressing
some of the psychological
[INAUDIBLE]?
We don't have a lot of
evidence, but we hope
to have some more [INAUDIBLE].
But that's exactly what
people are working on.